one of the things I talk to I know you
you were into it by Carl sargon of akkad
recently and I talked to him about this
I mean one of the things that seems to
me to be happening is with him and I
talked about this if you were to poll
the general public on this issue
and you were to say is someone who is
transitioned from being male to being
female a biological woman I think you
know I'm pretty comfortable that it
would be in the high 90s of people who
would say no to that
well of course because you've told them
this person is biologically male and
they've now transitioned to be a woman
right you don't change biology when you
transition do everything you can to fit
that biology and make yourself as
comfortable as you can't be but
transition is never 100% perfect and yet
if I were to go on national television
or radio or write a piece in the
newspaper saying a person who's
transitioned is not biologically the sex
which they claim to now be or the gender
which they claim to now be you you would
you would be destroyed overnight yeah so
essentially we now live in a situation
where the opinion of a tiny minority of
people is the one that is allowed to be
heard and to be spoken and the opinion
of the overwhelming majority of the
public is the one that is not allowed to
be spoken and not allowed to be heard
yeah is that accurate I would say so
yeah like its controversial I've even
seen trans women be banned from Twitter
simply for saying that their biological
males they're not calling over people
biological males are simply saying look
I'm a trans woman okay I see myself as a
woman but I am biologically male so
release it pretty much said that exact
message and she got banned for it III
known countless trans women who that has
happened to so Eva's and really can't
say it even we're not allowed to say it
I don't know what do you think of the
long-term implications of that I think
it gives a very misleading idea of what
we are I think it makes it look as
though we are a lot more like unhinged
like we really deny the reality that it
also sidelines biological women and
biological
as well because it says that a man's
issue is no longer about like testicular
cancer or women's issue is no longer
about pregnancy and you see this when
you have these more intersectional more
progressive women's rights groups in
particular where they'll be considered
talking about period sirs but it's
problematic if it's what if you got
trans women in a room because not all
women have periods not all women can get
pregnant it's the same you see it with
men's groups as well well not all men
have you know like you know some men
have periods some men can give birth and
there was a we remember the name of the
group there was a group a couple of days
ago that was saying like yes men can get
pregnant they seal you yes that's the
great thing about that is you know if
men could get pregnant they'd do it
better
[Music]
you
[Music]